all right for this last video there are
three things that I really want to
stress the first of which is these tools
are so useful and so awesome and when I
first learned about them I was really
intimidated and didn't see how they
could apply to me and that was a mistake
I should have just gotten in there and
played around more because I think I
would be more comfortable now the second
thing is in case you haven't heard me
say it enough read the documentation
it's awesome while you're playing around
with it read some documentation try it
out see what you can do I've even been
in the chat room asking I've been
looking for buggy pages so I could debug
them and people are really helpful
they'll give you a page that they think
really could use some help
third of all a lot of these tabs that
these videos have gone over do similar
things a lot of them have to do with how
long executing a certain thing takes and
that can be intimidating if you know
there's a problem but you're not sure
where to start that's okay something
that works best for you might not be the
same thing that works best for somebody
else once you figure it out it will get
easier and as a little bonus there is
this device mode that I showed you a
little bit at the beginning but I want
to play around with it now so it's this
little it looks like a little phone next
to the search button so I this is what
it looks like without it this is my
regular code my regular code pen I'm
going to click this little button and
here this is an Apple iPad this is what
it would look like and it functions to I
click the more button and it just does
it it even I can change the network so
if somebody is on Wi-Fi in case my page
is big enough where that's gonna make a
difference this is an e polar quote
because she's fantastic
um so there's your own devices you can
also just make it your own so like well
how would it look on something you know
this size and you can try it and see how
it goes
it's an awesome tool I hope you guys
have enjoyed these videos have fun
playing around with the dev tools